lui c'est le plus grand rapace déjà
c'est une bonne manière formation peut
faire jusqu'à 4 mètres 4 mètres
d'envergure pour les plus grands
spécimens se condor des andes est l'une
des sept espèces de vautours de l'espace
rambouillet une espèce originaire
d'amérique latine très menacé comme
beaucoup de ses congénères
c'est des espèces qui sont mal aimés du
fait de ballades c'est un peu bizarre
comme oiseau ça fait peur
il ya tout l'imaginaire qui va avec du
charognard un carnivore qui mangent des
cadavres ça fait beaucoup pour un oiseau
pour redonner ses lettres de noblesse
aux rapaces l'espace rambouillet a
participé pour la deuxième fois à la
journée internationale du vautour les
retours c'est un peu c'est les
équarrisseurs de la nature sur le
vétéran de la nature dans le sens où
grâce à eux il n'y a pas de maladies qui
se répandent dans nos espaces naturels
dans nos montagnes
c'est un peu la fin de la chaîne
alimentaire démonstration échanges avec
les fauconniers soutien de programmes
les vautours fauves - ou encore pape ont
séduit alors le retour de l'himalaya
c'est le grand que tu peux voir là tu
vois qu'il vienne le qui vient de lever
la pâte comme ça ils sont très
impressionnantes un animal que j'aime
beaucoup
globalement les rapaces parce que c'est
des animaux qui volent d'une manière
magnifique quoi et
et sont très impressionnants très gros
j'aime bien c'est une espèce protégée et
c'est beau et j'aime bien les voir
l'espace rambouillet la france accueille
quatre espèces différentes
seuls les vautours fauves ne sont pas
menacés